okay guys I wanted to do a follow-up to
a story that we did on the Rubin report
last week which I hope you guys saw it
was this crazy video of a fight on the F
train in New York City the subway where
a girl was relentlessly and mercilessly
taunting a male who was bigger than her
and it's unclear whether they knew each
other I don't think they did but it's
not a hundred percent clear taunting
taunting taunting getting in his face he
kind of moved away from her she
continued to get in his face scream at
him belittle him and eventually she
slapped him and then he immediately
slapped her back now this was a tall big
guy significantly bigger than her and he
whacked her open open hand but he
whacked her good then a completely a
completely crazy melee broke out and all
hell broke loose people screaming and
just circus anyway we did a video on it
on the Rubin report and I had two female
guests who both basically agreed that
men should not hit women regardless of
the circumstances there were slight
caveat to that and I pray basically
agreed with that premise that men should
not hit women and I think I was trying
to take the high road and I think I
alluded to this at least in a question
and that may be what he should have done
is as awful as what she did was and I
believe in equality of the sexes as
awful as what she did was both both
because of the the sex part of it and I
know I just said I believe in equality
and I do but because I have a general
belief that a man shouldn't hit a woman
generally and because he was so much
bigger that maybe what he should have
done was just get off the subway at the
next stop no matter how egregious and
wrong what she did was anyway the
comments section was people were going
completely berserk on me of course
fighting with each other it is YouTube
but people were really disappointed in
in my remarks that were saying that I'm
being too politically correct and that
this is a consistent problem of the left
and if women if feminists want equality
then they have to be treated equally and
if she wants to be treated equally well
then if she hits this man that he has
every right to hit back anyway it's a
multi-layered thing but I think maybe I
was a little dismissive of this man's
right to defend himself by the way the
charges were dropped against him he did
have charges issued she the charges on
her Stan
and anyway it's a multi-layered thing
and I think I was trying to take
somewhat of the high road on it I
suppose but yeah sometimes I guess you
do have to fight back no matter how I'm
politically correct it is